I'll send you some JPEGs no I don't take
it you got her that's not yeah look
Chris does need head shots and and
though I want to just put telling the
rest here
there has been when I do a lot of stand
up you know I've been doing a long time
sure and there's this there's this whole
[ __ ] thing where people go they see
you and they this kid reminds us okay a
Brian Cowen before he became you know
what did the master that he is and it's
funny because I know I've been a huge
influence on you know open we used to
feature no and so I've been a big big
fool just my physicality and here you
are here you come kind of bending around
and no no I don't think so so so I want
to say that you have found your own like
the other day I watched your stand-up
and I'm being condescending here say
it's for the first time okay actually
you actually sprouted wings you actually
grown all your feathers and does ready
to release you from the boat do not say
it and we're not saying I want anybody
else to say that you are like you are my
products okay nobody we're doing that
one for me get out of that shadow yeah
and you're a sight for no wonder you've
young no you know haze okay you've grown
your full set of mature wings get out
there and fly here's the deal be scared
usual a that yeah and then you suck him
into it as well and he's like oh yeah
you're saying about the end don't have a
quarterback comparison thing it's not
like that what do you mean what I'm
saying is I never knew who you were what
Wow until years after I started stand-up
whoa you playing in coffee shop know and
what I know eclipsed you oh and that
okay and that's okay what's new don't
think it's okay but people started to be
like who's that guy on crystally is
instagram dumb time no you know what can
I do another football reference okay
he's drew blessed oh you're Tom Brady it
isn't like that yeah is that more like
not like that is it's not like just
because you're making your voice lowered
I hope you could up big I'm getting
serious now
no you're not getting an aureus listen
up okay what's up fly oh no and I know
what you're saying that but I don't like
better your dad but dude can I tell you
guys something
well obviously I this is the craziest
thing but for months now I've been
driving around and like the other day
like I would drive I'll be war I was I'm
going to the street the other day and
some guy
and he says why and I'm like what and
he's driving right this drives by sunset
eyes yeah yeah it says on sunset apart
and I get a coffee I get I get a coffee
at the coffee bean the other day and the
guys like won't you want me to put down
your name for the drink and he says or
should I just put it under why and I was
like what okay how like not just kidding
Chris and I was like okay sure
and then so he's like my office no no
it's not just a [ __ ] hilarious a
weird interesting story so um I was at a
meeting the other day and I sit down and
I guy goes hey Chris why and but he
looked at me and and and I and I was
like I don't understand what were you
saying he was like never mind anyway you
know I've been going to therapy a lot
right so I say to my therapist I'm
telling her this I'm telling it the
water I don't understand what people are
saying why it's got me to joke about
putting why in the coffee cup and she
says and she says mmm and this is what
we came the war that you know I don't
know I know I know she said maybe
they're wondering why you were would do
the fighter in the kid after you know
man hey Josh okay because your
girlfriend said them yeah she said I
said cuz it done how to career oh oh and
and and and and and I and I got over 10
million downloads does it matter
yeah Chris yeah but then just so weird
cuz there because then your agent called
me and they were saying how grateful
they are because they go a man listen
they go listen Chris doing his stand-up
thing strange in this podcast world we
know you're the podcast king we'd love
for you to have ngratulations
yeah I do a composer I just look at this
screenshot I took for you these are
videos of me on the as YouTube died I
just say millions
hey bro but that's what not to do a hot
cat alright you know what you're not
you're not gonna sit here you might have
your bigger than the bottom in one point
we don't hear about that stop I say ah
hey B can I burn easily come out here
because yeah I feel like Chris has
changed since snapchat went away cuz you
ain't look at me cuz you were kind of
you know you're kind of a vine stone no
no you have rhinestones OS you can say
name is receiver seconds yo
no you're really good at vine like
behind your [ __ ] though with them once I
went to a minute but uh you know how
long's dude you know a little do I have
was you're getting sick second no matter
what app comes out I master okay okay
don't act like here it let you lost
something like you'll order kids what no
no don't I confuse thank God I'm not on
tinder all right mad you well finish
your sentence your [ __ ] senses wait
let's switch gears because one thing
that's really bothering me but I noticed
right behind it I need to hear about it
sub mill you have no hair on your
forearms now explain why had to take it
off I know I actually don't know if I
can technically talk about it but what I
can say is had to do it for a part for a
movie yeah but I don't think I can talk
about what the part one you just know
what you play alright but we know it's
not like a comic role no it's a drama
it's a drama drama
yeah so you're actually having a big
deep all and get into a cartoon and and
and know it no I don't know but you're
being condescending it very credit and
if it's like broad stroke I'm about
release I say is range the people like
when I run when people describe Chris
they don't go range no no no there's not
a lot of what's the word Lane later
people were coming up to me and they
were like what's going on behind your
eyes in on Ted what's going on behind
your face it's like your face is the
face for your face right what's behind
that right there were like cuz that's
crazy what's going on yeah I like the
rock of comedy like anything you're
gonna do your crisp but not rock and
everything yeah but be okay but there is
no rain but this is gonna open up doors
okay man you get who if you become
famous throughout this like if you
become Don't Tell norm or use the word
more in that sense well no if you get
like more like if you jump up on a vinyl
vein but what if you become it if you
become somebody they want for serious
dramatic roles
more rolls then what then what's gonna
happen here you can get real mad you bet
you're gonna get punched up don't we
know but like in you but you can't help
it it's like a visceral
no really I'm on Chris we need a big
role do you hesitate to tell Brian you
don't have to feel this in me I've had
my share and I've turned my share down
don't look like that's something all
right
don't raise your eyebrow okay okay have
a mind of its own but okay don't don't
do that
okay I'm sorry three eyebrows calm when
you say okay all right don't [ __ ]
have your caterpillars go crazy all
right but so I've turned rolls down I've
chosen to keep my career where it is
right because you're right like you like
the private life I have not found victim
to the public embrace of celebrity oh
because it keeps me focused and I do
what it is that I want to do stay humble
I like this and you're putting on it
yeah no I think it's a good thing it's
all about being positive all right now
listen what you went to Toronto I hooked
you up my ball boy Joe Gerson yeah your
ball or your boy because you looked
human to me I create my ladies ooh
you're pushing this guy but everybody
you could put this is a large cast in a
row he's brought this up but I yeah I
wanted to say of course you know can you
put cereal and milk in him or or did you
mean to say boy instead of a bowl as you
proved a vagina I mean you know I want
to actually FaceTime him later and see
if there's any any lucky charms on him
hey let's also hurt me oh you're being
so disrespectful in this podcast when we
haven't even [ __ ] gotten or get into
the mule is my now my friend Joel
Revolution MMA yeah I went to I went to
we decide I want to get to me when he's
a great guy and as my friend now no not
hold on he's my friend first he's your
friend
he's I granted you an audience with him
now here's what I'm getting our well it
bothers me what what is that you took a
couple of classes with him at his at his
school and now you're asking Brendan
where you can train here I need him to
cut them up now and I want
say something before we get it done
happy okay you said them up before we
get into how you're going to Train I
want you to know something and I mean
this so seriously and so sincerely I'm
going to say thank you when I took a nap
a Rip Van Winkle map for five years I
woke up with my hair way too long my
nails way too long and my [ __ ] beard
way hydrated and dehydrating another
five years left hey Greg that's the main
question hold on okay are they waving me
up after my Rip Van Winkle nap you've
been training
I mean training yeah I mean so can your
shirt in your shorts and your undies
every single [ __ ] day right you still
be in the multi you don't last one round
bro what's wrong with me
you understand me I'm talking about
hiding under my nails that I can't make
a fist I be he did do jujitsu for
pleasure a day I know her dad Chris did
I know he did for six years and I want
to say this [ __ ] you why [ __ ] your
[ __ ] oh wow jujitsu okay if you know
step to me when you're ready phone is a
that's not my dude I turn my [ __ ] off
here's brother dude don't mind I don't
like how you say bro after that and
that's your phone you know why because
you're [ __ ] terrible with your phone
no the word or loss on town on all the
times cuz cuz I keep things quiet right
well although he's checking text now
okay hey [ __ ] look who it is Chris hey
setup over Thank You Man where because I
was I was unbreakable well how does it
you set him up and on me because you
know why dude what is like setup unit
you get really lame yeah yeah but you
know what it is dude it's about like raw
talent yeah I don't think II think you
have that listen you're not malleable
you know you're headstrong see thank you
for bringing this up yes I got a way
better way to do it
I'll break a little bullet in your face
I'm good I mean I'm breakable
what are you gonna train you're gonna
train MMA in case you got a what put
your hands on somebody What's Up
[ __ ]
don't get too jumpy I'll show to the
microwave what's up if you feel froggy
leap I'm ready good that's all
all right Mowgli what Mowgli from Zulu
below that's what Mowgli means frog so
wanted to be a little Mowgli and [ __ ]
leap
huh into the jaws this snake dude I
don't like the wrap you up I don't like
the animal references man
don't shush me bro that is [ __ ] weird
that's not I'm very weird
you get a weird Vince Chris what when
all of a sudden did you start to get
healthy today toffee I was the last of
nowhere I eat these sex bro I got a
trainer come the house I mean write any
fiction with a shirt off yeah I know
after you you don't have a bad body at
all you know I hope you because you know
why because on a dime I got I do squat
your legs are terrible no they're not
all right okay I have a because I'm 37
and I just feel like you know yeah I'm
gonna break down in the next eight years
if I don't feel that way right you said
yeah I've been doing theaters and stuff
for realz it's work right up there is
that what well yeah I mean I just don't
get fat I mean well I mean I don't think
I really run that risk yet maybe like
when I'm like 55 the one good thing
about you is that you are very [ __ ]
consistent disciplined yeah for for a
guy who you wouldn't think you if you
decide to it you will show up every day
that I like that Mary I was never get
every day I never think I was like I
like a guy but yeah when I first met you
I thought you had horrible uh drug
addiction yeah and you were super
undisciplined yeah turns out you don't
drink you know drugs you're super to
having all the other ten span of a small
pointer okay
you never have I understand you never
had far sorry I fell asleep no III
totally seem like that and I understand
that and I even kind of emote that but I
am so disciplined yeah why is that in
where's that come from uh your dad's
very much that what he is yeah um I
don't know man
III Italian working I don't know I want
to be I want to be good and something
and like I also there's not many things
I like and when I find something I do
like I wanted I want to and I don't look
at it like you know I want to be better
than other guys I'm not competitive at
all like
that way I just want to be good for me I
would I good you know like when I did
you Jitsu I did it for six years and I
got to the point where like guys were
like going to be doing tournaments and
wanting to [ __ ] and I was like I
don't want to do this yeah you know what
I mean like that but yeah I rabbit hole
yeah it's my hobby you know and and with
stand up I turned my my might what I
love into my career and that's amazing
for me because but then I got so I don't
have a hobby you know really your
brother said that you as long as he can
remember
you've lived for one thing yeah and that
is to make people laugh yeah you just
that was your Emma always man even in
high school I know I used to be a silly
[ __ ] goose which is funny because you
and I were talking about how like how
stand up for us we take seriously right
and how there are so many guys that we
see and they've been doing Santa for
like 10 years 12 years and it's like hey
bro what are you doing what are you
doing you're just you're doing hanging
around the comedy store what say that
guy's name before we're about to do a
show bring us I hate watch so it'd be
the equivalent of when you getting ready
to fight if they showed you a guy you
knocked out non-stop okay Brian goes
before you go up there check this guy on
it stand up oh how I I'm watching it and
I'm like his mouth fell open I go ahead
and take it but it's so bad you can dude
watching he's been doing for 20 years on
holy [ __ ] I'll let you [ __ ] up my
[ __ ] frame of mind really good screw
you oh yeah I hate seeing that well it
the the problem well the difference
between like the reason why if fighting
is cool one of the reasons is there's a
winner and in and did I make it either
best there's a winner in stand-up done
well okay true you can you can be very
successful and be considered the best
but you can be I can hate somebody's
comedy and they could still have a
thriving career yeah they're winning you
know what I mean they're still winning
right you the the winning in comedy
would be ticket sales correct I bet for
me it'd be just people laughing really
number two right like that's the real
win yeah when you when you do stand-up
no matter where you are whoever the
audience and you crush rooms yeah that
for a comic
yeah it's not the old bag of tricks Oh
anybody come up with 20 minutes over the
years and just keep on saying I've seen
that you know over and over I can never
understand but if you're always coming
up with new [ __ ] always doing that thank
you
Bryan Callen you know you you you find
that immensely satisfying as opposed to
selling out suckers with you know you're
out there like waiting here I mean yeah
they're mind but uh the other day we we
you saw the Kathy Griffin stone oh yeah
yeah right
do you guys have any idea how successful
do you have any close successful shoes
oh yeah she's made a lot of money
I might not you know she's worth like 50
60 mils I know her tours are like all
sold out yeah no I do I knew that
economy Award for comedy special six
specials nominate for Kenny what not
Academy Awards uh I mean yeah he owned
that yeah number monster Kathy's always
been once [ __ ] hilarious
she that would that style that she does
I mean she murders that style you know I
mean it's not for everyone is it now
well Kay I don't know I'm having Cathy
some anything going on new music all
[ __ ] aside it Kathy's into an improv
and on a high level and working really
hard at characters for literally 30
years morally right I'm doing like
people you know because well curricular
like did like a that's not funny it's
not creative either I don't think it was
I thought those poor taste yeah and so
and we got emails be like how are you to
criticize her I'm like well I can
criticize because that's that money
never had to end up his fun like her
stand up do what she does she'll even
well yeah it's very fun mom nobody's
saying she's not funny but over the
we're not but like went when her her to
do that was just like wow yeah and and
it I don't think she was even trying to
be funny really yeah I don't know I
don't know it is like that her defense
was I'm a comic well that is true so
then you're gone well then it's funny
the way I look at it is this Kathy made
a bad choice she said she was sorry she
may hate I fry them so I don't think
that we should I don't think that her
career should be over no you know CNN
violent responses drunk yeah no she's
ill show so get it back but she's she
took a serious hit
yeah and I think she take it wise I
don't think she takes a hit I think
she's bigger from
maybe maybe Ashley is a smart baby but I
would never do something like that but I
actually is a smart play name one show
you that you can turn on right now
that's not talking about Ted well and if
you disagree with Trump which the
majority of America does fiscally
they're probably buying the ticket or
show he'll talk about it so turn this
whole thing into an hour and a whole
hour Trump's a boolean or all that so I
think the only thing he's already saying
that she's already saying all these rich
white men are old white men are smart
are winning and beating me up and it's
like my and I are like free speech and
we're all like well look at us and she
was now getting bullied like I think
that the only thing that would like what
she did was she made she made livers
look bad you know yeah she made uh and
and I I've met her I've worked with her
she she's great but and and I've made
dummies [ __ ] - dude I I was somebody got
I won one of these days years ago for
one day I was the talk about how I
[ __ ] did something what I do I'll
tell you in a second but uh they they
you know this stuff comes and it goes
and it's fine and in a casual but not a
bad girls not no no no same great either
yeah she's a she's a she's a really
funny very tight and you say [ __ ] and
sometimes it to get a cut and look look
she did this photo shoot and she did the
thing with the bloody Trump head I can
imagine
you're there and you're like oh [ __ ]
and if the vibe is right like I always
take a silly picture like this people
are laughing by the way yeah yeah and
then I know is have you seen the footage
so no one's laugh and she did they do
the picture is very serious and she goes
to Fatah Shias you don't probably prison
for this and hear me in trouble two
years yeah probably
well I didn't you I put it she knew the
word because I actually think it was
very calculated I think it's a great PR
mood he said I would never do something
to this extreme but everyone's talking
about her but my point is she'll take
you but my point is once you do
something what you say something you you
only you own it until then you know and
then when that happens like I got a
blasted took part to bring it back up
because I tell you the that whole
yesallwomen hashtag to remember that yes
yeah well you know basically yeah it was
it was remember that guy in Santa
Barbara that shot up the a bunch of
people you might he was going to kill
that holster
already right well no but no what
happened was he killed a bunch of people
men and women yeah and he put out a
video early on before before through out
of mail and these women would see that
he was yeah he was when he had watered
them and and so then then people took
that as a hate thing against women and
he killed all these women which he
killed a bunch of guys to I actually
think he killed more guys anyways on the
street I couldn't get into so so they
turned it in and a bunch of women would
tweet about it now um and they said yet
you know uh women would tweet stuff like
I was raped and that's not okay yes all
women and that's horrible and then
someone would be like I walk down the
street and a guy cat called me yes all
women and I said on what what I was not
saying on on this video that went viral
was women this isn't a problem for women
I was not saying that obviously that's
horrible that that happened not yeah
you're not you're not you're not
diminishing of course I haven't like
suffering or women go what I was saying
was this guy focusing on how this this
guy is mentally ill yes and that's the
problem it's not that he hated women
it's not that he's a guy he's a mentally
ill it's not that he's a guy and and I
was extreme to explain him it may be the
same with a bigger problem yeah Oh some
women
well what when I man versus woman right
it's not no it's it meant a little human
there's a huge problem too and he killed
men - yeah and and and and I can maybe I
didn't say it is year you [ __ ] up well
what most normal women's lives don't
matter
no but what happened was Huffington Post
or whatever they took not they made the
headline of the worst comedian speaks
out against yes or women he not even
people people to even read the article
millinery auditorium for the help of the
ED pillow Huffington Post editorial
board so they so they played me you know
which is fine and honestly I stand by
what I thought hits on it and I was
trying to make I was trying to be light
and I was trying to be funny about it
when I wasn't even talking about it like
this I was trying to be funny about it
and I they get out there and people just
look like one whose day yeah slow funny
and you put on your own
no no no no uh now picture there's
usually a picture of it potential of an
impulse Alan chance too much yeah John
place no reason I don't think we should
give the monopolist now how many product
has dumped but anyway uh anyway um the
the it was because it was undateable is
coming out and so I felt like you know
it was ours promote if I didn't help
undateable yet did [ __ ] it did it any
publisher which are you handle it well I
heard you how you kind of rebut it again
and and that's the thing that you love
women and dudes but there's no there's
just there's literally there's literally
very little wiggle room sometimes when a
mob gets involved in oh that movement
well you're in it will you buck against
that movement your label this is my
problem with the with the progressive
left is that you're labeled all kinds of
things that you're just not yeah you
know and so it earlier for later your
fan base who know you very well know
what we real there's a ton of them I
like what yeah they got like anyone's
got Chris's terrible person no no only
doesn't know you might have been like
well but they can put a lot of pressure
on sponsors on people's on your online
ID let me know they'll put a lot of
blood like pressure on yours but who was
the guy who he was a CEO of a company
and he I think he had voted against prop
8 which was against gay marriage you
know he's got his religious views or
whatever but let me tell you man and you
know this is in their right to but
Barbara Streisand and she was a gay son
and an obviously very emotional issue
with a huge gay fan base but Barbra
Streisand a lot of other people did a
whole bunch created a whole bunch of
noise and he didn't get the job all
those people just showed on your bed so
becomes it you know and that's again
that's in there right and and you know
it's it's remember back not too long ago
if you were gay you didn't get a job
right if you are gay you got fired so
this is all kind of like comes back to
the pendulum swimming swing in one way
or another but bounce man you've got to
be it's it's today in today's world you
have to be very careful well Jon Ronson
the book so you've been publicly shamed
have you read it no I mean it talks all
about this and how bad it is to to
publicly shame somebody and how like a
lot of the people who get publish it
publicly shame to end up committing
suicide have you have you seen uh
uh reading this article on shoes uh the
Playmate two years ago complete
dimepiece but she was in the gym and she
goes oh yes I can't forget I name and it
showed like an older lady out of shape
I took a picture she blasted that out
she lost everything boy yeah a matter of
fact she's getting sued now or she just
should be sued that's really rude yeah
and she had to go into hiding because
yeah she and Jack well that's not okay
Janet no he's not you [ __ ] most of the
woman's image yes her body so she got
banned for the gym from her life she
shot woman's taken to court she should
she had to go live with her parents and
she's in hiding now she's getting death
threat you need you need to be that's
too much yeah now she's getting bullied
you need to that's so now that mob goes
that's not fair to do that and then you
do it to you guys are doing which I know
kid I know so how do you have and I
think to piggyback on what you're saying
is that people will make mistakes people
will bully does that mean their whole
life for the rest of their life
we'rewe're snow I don't everyone I feel
just made a yellow Finnell over nowadays
you can see it though nowadays you could
pay for it for the rest of your life as
and you can never get a job again yeah
they go oh you were that girl and you
get you you got that scarlet letter well
here's a sports broadcaster who he had a
thriving career for thirty years I mean
there's a black running back he just
messed up give me the Greek Jesus we got
a little monkey run meaning lie and he
didn't even mean not at all excellent
context yeah got fired it's so with that
I'm mad that Jimmy the only guy who got
I don't know Jim look at that monkey run
Jimmy the Greek why I say don't okay
though that would be huge like bount
like bouncing around he just [ __ ] up
to do you know represent both this is a
black case for a monkey
it would be us on context I love Jimmy
the Greek it but um yeah yeah bring up
your people that very famous yeah you
guys right two younger is it first kind
of Miami Scalia to say something to the
effect of black guys are he talked about
how slavery has slate how slavery I
can't really exactly I didn't do that
how slavery etiquette how the strongest
woman in song has made a bread course to
Brenda and breed and dad like that guy
could run well there's no her like for
that they said that on HIV the Greek
Cecily can be fired for sure was like no
big guys like um no this guy's swing
athletic play for you
Jesus li got monkey like cause he's like
spinning and I doing this thing and it
just had me about yeah my buddy my buddy
on black goes like this one during the
Greek Aaron he goes like and he was
built like just a brick [ __ ] some
great running react he goes he's
listening they talking about and he goes
like this
we're all looking at him and he goes he
loses it's true oh [ __ ] you saw this
where I recognize a lot of the time life
no it was a big huge news back in the
day iconic in 1985 oh they're cool yeah
mention forties here wow that's s [ __ ]
crazy yeah yeah I'm gonna watch the P's
and Q's but I also feel like there's a
lot of guys like using a Howard Stern
guys who don't you don't make try to
please everyone usually come out on top
yeah guys who are like I'm so scared to
say anything I'm just gonna ride the
fence or not stamp reaming they don't
make it and Entertainment well that in
radio well let's be honest and let's be
honest there are certain truths there
are certain truths that a lot of
different kinds of things that are very
uncomfortable to talk about or or string
up publicly like if you have an if you
have an opinion like you know track it
out but in nineteen fact if that's what
you like at the time if that's what you
believe you know and our doctor Howard
Stern on never forgot he said Magic
Johnson was back playing basketball in
you know after he had HIV because I'm
going to say what everybody's thinking
nobody wants to say no guy wants to get
want to play with him because they're
afraid they're going to catch something
because he might bleed on it right or
even sweat on them or snot on them
that's the reality of sports and the
fact the matter is those guys are
allowed to feel that way because it's
[ __ ] scary because I don't know right
we didn't know that much about how yeah
okay the excited consensus that you have
sex we had to have a blood transfusion
[ __ ] you man I your doesn't mean that
you're a bad person shock you but now
you have HIV what's the leap you have a
lease well I'm glad you were sad this
guy beat me up no I did not Brian
usually more blindside is only hard
because the video starts too late you
could have been the [ __ ] [ __ ] so
what happened I was the [ __ ] I put I
was there enjoy my afternoon and he
keeps pushing me pushing me I go dude I
mean physically yeah like Keith was me
where
we're a probing studio he keeps slapping
me in the face to go dude I'm telling
you good slug him I kept saying it's
rough house Sunday no now we have shirts
called Russell Sunday on Sunday bro and
then he goes then he took his wallet out
to his watch off and started to come at
me and I realized of the Bears angry and
then I tried to back out of it because
it was your idea well Sunday and when
the flying Kimora was what yeah through
my head it's just a rug burn but then I
don't know why you listen sorry I think
but here's the deal because you took all
the skin off my head no no let me ask
you a question this is the important
part
yeah did you learn your lesson thank you
you know because life is about growth
right not change growth in learn your
lesson or lesson I be honest we don't if
I kind of comparable honest with you I
didn't use anything against him like I
kind of balled up as opposed to actually
using the things that I know so you
think if you use the things you know
with a one way different I'm gonna say
this okay you say they don't have to
always prep what you're going to say
with I'm gonna say this you just say
we're all listening button ask me the
question again I'm only gonna answer it
this way I don't mean it can be serious
I'm gonna be dead is here to know that I
don't [ __ ] around when I talk about this
kind of stuff yeah yeah I want to know
the truth yes may know and I'm you know
I gots me you have more experience on
the matter Brian like Billy real jujitsu
he does know six years yeah I do yeah I
do
you sure you totally change for two
atoms of not at train I mean I train
Street sports Beverly oh you do - dude
I'm I'm very comfortable on that okay
but put your thumb over all six years
that's fine but very I hate to drag this
out but nothing it's not fun to normally
group after Michael asked me the cash do
you think if you use your knowledge on
fighting and defending yourself that you
think with Brendon if you did that
instead of what you did that it would
have went way different I would have
kept him busy huh right I think Keith
would have I think he might maybe would
have consumed you like blood like ate
you
and [ __ ] you just for fun well not
even he didn't even wanna just be like I
god baby you do it again I told you it's
gonna happen I'm gonna Emily grab the
here you have less on top your scalp and
rip it off I said you get him he can be
busy
I don't know how busy he's gonna be if
you don't know what I got I don't know
what you got you're right that's the way
you understand that right
so on his muscle understand one thing
he's a [ __ ] killer and he is a beast
okay busy busy okay all read all I'm
that's a did I say anything
it's all you can do man I say anything I
can do yeah threat number anything no
it's like all good all right we get it
I'll tell youse gonna be busy is Chris
at this new gym like I'll be real busy
well I want to say this you want to say
this to you bro so I'm going to come to
that gym good and I'm going to use your
head to control your posture I'm gonna
grab that hair and I'm going to pull you
down look don't don't blink like that
and I'm gonna throw my legs around your
[ __ ] your body and neck Chris do you
put your hair in a ponytail you half
don't do that dude I have to do I don't
want to I don't want is getting loaded
so I have to wear half and now I got a
handle brother now I got a handle
brother okay man now I got a handle
brother all right I heard never came out
way back in the day we're always great
to grab not on that stupid [ __ ]
ponytail threw him in the old that's
what I'm gonna do to you
dude and you're always Gracie's key mola
that's right Wow yeah that's what
happens to you bro that's not I'm going
to throw you in yield and then they
that's not a term dude
yeah and then you go no I don't yeah I
don't I don't
that's the sound effect that goes on in
our [ __ ] I breathe until my breathing
I want to [ __ ] I want to go I want
you to come to the class I'll do when I
get you in a body lock put a little bit
where your diapers where your diapers
okay
good go you have your tongue come out of
your mouth and you say that but I'm just
saying wait Dave okay dude I'll mail be
so funny to a class with you for real we
would have so much fun
would you guys or would you get nothing
done because you guys are more
[ __ ] maybe that's already it knocking
happy 50 we're not trainer I said every
time he goes if I said Hansen delete
Alan to you you know how are they I'd
say it's give me it's gonna be like
wrangling cats its give me a night
measure I mean I know you had a fact I'm
not gonna set the fact forget I ever
approach here
wait you Rogan said that you are like
boxing and sparring yeah you're getting
hit in the head sometimes that's a real
bad idea for you it's a bad ear sing to
be on it gets him really angry I mean
you have you know well okay why's it get
you angry I know that it doesn't get me
angry I don't I'd like to hear it I just
don't get why you want to get hit in the
head it's resi
50 he wanted to talk to me he get
somebody like I'm not even talking to
you about this not only want I'll ask
him a question like a technique question
he's like I'm not I'm not answered I'm
not talking I get that I'd rather talk
about I get why he wouldn't want it
doesn't matter yeah yeah it's like right
I remember I got embarrassed with him
because I said I said should I get the
plant protein of the whey protein in my
smoothie and he looks me goes it doesn't
matter does it though yeah [ __ ]
well I'll never ask [ __ ] dumb
questions like that hey now you can't do
under
or you're not getting in the head and I
got him the hex code a schism I'm really
young yeah well good 30 very young I'm
yeah but and you look 37 right jus no
I'm saying not to be a dick with you
know that right you look 30 you say
every bit of 30 wa1 that you are
chock-full you're you're 37 cup is
chock-full the brim you still in oh I
get this low stories for like that mix
up Cory what would you say of course you
were the day I turned 38 how old will I
look I'll tell you this you I don't yeah
when you're 38 today to turn eight you
look 38 okay on a draw was your brain
it's like it's a bad thing
I'm just saying that it and it is the
way you're saying it is a bad thing and
it's making me angry
no I don't turn 38 for a long time I
just turned 37 but you got to stop
saying that no I know but you could mule
you could mule drugs in those [ __ ]
eyelids
you could mule drugs in those saggy so
you guys shut your eyes man
all right uh no you're making me sad I
know and don't cut your hair because
there goes that career no dude I'm a
commander on meth every day that'll be
less detrimental your career I probably
have to [ __ ] cut my hair soon do some
kind of [ __ ] cool part probably okay
some of them probably look like you're
all asked me to do so you're dragging
what god I hit throwing your phone why
look for a guy's been on his phone all
the time do you have such a small phone
why don't you have a big phone like mine
an ample phone dude that'd piss me off
Terral flesh okay that's a dumb [ __ ]
question question it's a dumb question
gay man you [ __ ] get so many hits and
[ __ ] and this podcast is successful and
you ask [ __ ] like that and I was bad
Chris well then I just thought you bro I
want the [ __ ] small one okay next
question
haha there's another class I'll change
the subject all right now your your guy
Oh action movies and TV use a podcast
and I'll be your podcaster besides this
obviously is your favorite podcast
what's your favorite movie of the year
you know what we need
you don't know wait I'm gonna go get a
drink you guys you keep asking like wet
yourself down a little bit
mm-hmm go away yourself down you've been
dry since we started I'm not dry I just
have no ends if I created the spin-off
podcast congratulations which is a
spinoff from well yeah we better your
biggest think it's just spin-off all
right well okay what do you talk on a
mean spin-off I'm taking what you guys
do and I'm running with no it's fine but
it's a spinoff now listen all right well
how it's called you wells go out
congratulations and did I take you 13
seconds to come up with a title or did
you put any effort into anything thought
about a few I thought about it for a
little bit in me and then thought of
congratulations and I was like that's
perfect
I saw something a tattoo of your podcast
up it seems you're cool lean into legion
okay why do you call them babies because
I don't know why you hate
babies eh what's up babies dirt it's I'm
of all female fans cool like no [ __ ]
that it's so cool if you're a dude in
your baby and I mean that he caught on
delivers by useless for the believers
but I'll tell you I'll tell you right
now I'm honestly starting the podcast
for two reasons one is monetary that you
know my make a mom McMunn my you know
it's it's important for me to get Brinks
trucks to back up into my car okay
there's that oh I don't applaud to get
Dunbar I could just open up there the
back of their van and drop that load and
just have loads of cash is siphoning
into my window and and the other one is
because I'm genuinely trying to start a
cult okay oh wow what are you going to
do to your club is are you going to be
one of those is it going to be like
where the girls have to service nobody's
gonna die it's not a suit I know I want
us to like that startup but just say
like yeah but we're gonna run into the
woods and everyone's gonna just listen
to me and it's going to be a lot of
drama and heavy [ __ ] don't know that's
so it let's so about you though is it's
going to be can guys join it as well
guys can join it as well okay well
what's with the progressed but they have
to always it's a I mean it I'm six-two
so I'm taller than most people but they
can never like they can be taller than
me I don't want to judge but they always
have to crowd be under me oh that that's
all that well so it's all act self
aggrandizement you're you're there what
do you talk about with them daily it
changes it'll change but I'd starting
with the podcast so but what you're
having a cult so what would you guys do
if they come to your cult and join your
call what would their what they retain
being well it's a community you know and
and we we harvest or we're going to
harvest our own vegetables and fruits
and I'm not gonna do any of it but
they're gonna they're going to do all of
that and they're gonna come to me for
guidance in their life and when I say
something to them about what they should
do they're going to do it and yeah if
they don't I mean then so it's a call
get read in the cult uh yeah I mean I
don't know what I'm gonna call it yet
like what do you talk about on your
podcast so you don't have a close
- bounce laughs it's just you talking to
a mic you think bill burr I just [ __ ]
go and have to rely on anybody else
because I know sometimes a lot of times
the people are late
don't push and I don't have to split the
money [ __ ] little [ __ ] boys yeah hey
hey I want to hold on hey and it's so
greedy dude you're so [ __ ] greedy
don't be so greedy
look at you you vacuum cleaner I talk
about everything that goes on in my life
and then in the [ __ ] past week and you
never have guessed not yet I mean I
might one day but you don't have
anything going on you're like it's just
unset a routine you just try this sauce
always I do not agree about all gates
let it come out the gates like this
why did my podcast come out the gates
like this hey ya mad bro
but you just get on and you talk about
like stand up and then like Starbucks or
yeah yeah but why but yeah and I know it
sounds weird
it does sound weird but why when it came
out it came out of the gates like that
ah yeah why did it do that haha what
yeah well you're doing the chores
whatever now so is it now is it hmm it's
like that yeah yeah yeah you know I mean
every now and then there's a gate that's
like ah you know do I'll fill it's so
annoying but it doesn't how long do you
talk for now
one hour yeah it's you and your
producers just me man you bounce it off
of him and I don't care I'll just say
what the [ __ ] I want
wow man I do what you want when and how
high up do it and people keep letting me
and it's once a way you can do that it's
not the week that dude and you can do
that in your life Chris will dish it
like this
somebody'll come up to us and start
talking to us and I'll usually
inevitably be a little bit crazy and
even though they've been around and
he'll just like just like I'll turn the
heading a question here is what are you
doing or or the other day becoming
stormy in him we're talking we're
learning the middle of conversation guy
comes with twinges hey man hits both of
and Chris goes wrong you don't see time
a conversation yes like oh yeah he's
like get little if you want to take
pictures I'm willing no conversation you
guys like yeah he's like while finish
this and with a picture yeah yeah I'm
like yeah man where's your manners yeah
yeah willingness deep conscious guy just
yeah yeah and and and and I won't do
that but we're actually talking about
something you know what I mean like but
and then and then you'll be talking and
you're just talking to having a
conversation and then [ __ ] it you know
like yeah to agree yeah I don't know you
know throw some [ __ ] in life and I watch
it I just that one guy goes don't do
that don't you man hey man you played in
workaholics yeah man oh so anyway yeah
it is rough ah Chris Alex what happened
to me I just hang in there Chris just
don't do that man don't do that what's
that will you do it I'll turn around
okay here's what you guys don't do that
don't I love doing the guy who said yeah
and you guys perform the Nagus yeah you
were there you saw you right on I love
you too I think they panic cuz I'll ask
you a question if they know the answer
to but they don't know what to say it's
like when I met Al Pacino and I go I
watched you Scarface Siksika ha I was 48
48 or something like oh I was like oh no
and you know he did he goes oh hey what
about B what about once all Harrison for
we're in the final but here's some four
guys buying a rose window user testing
bang goes I get the piece and it really
is actually the fee sign so I got [ __ ]
but but people is funny that people
don't know what to say but but like oh
girl came up to me at Starbucks the
other day and she says hey are you
famous and I said not if you don't know
who I am yeah
and she goes like this Oh yo well and I
know she fell Akemi like she made me
feel like an idiot yeah we all wants to
say what time so I've been I did this
thing I did this thing on my podcast
where I was talking about or no I did it
on Instagram where I was talking about
rude boys and kings and I would like be
on it
ma'am I'd be like hey look I'm gonna
find ting xandred was and I did it
because Drake came out that album was
talking about saying King's Andrew boys
and the king is a girl that like you you
[ __ ] with and a rude boy is your buddy
or some I don't know everything what
they are but uh people in Toronto were
coming up to being like a rude boy you
know things like if it happen multiple
times a day so but and and it's fine but
you know like I had a lot of days off so
I'd be like sitting in a coffee shop and
people would would would literally pop
their head into a coffee shop and be
like hey rude boy and now here's the
deal okay I know what share make sure
what they're doing is they want to
connect with me and I want me to know
that they're a fan yeah which is off
that's awesome but what they don't
realize that they're doing is everyone
in the coffee shop they don't know who I
am
okay so when that guy pops in and says
hey rude boy everybody thinks oh now
what is vit yeah look to me too for an
explanation okay yeah and that end up
glare a rude boy right from yeah exactly
and that's shitty
and that's yeah for me to be in that
situation yes okay so it happened a few
times so so now I got to be like haha
and instead of that I needed this twice
now to this happen two different times
and I and I and I and the second time I
said I I looked at the guy and I went
like this
ahaha okay like I'm like haha and Danny
crazy and I [ __ ] deflected the
uncomfortable [ __ ] to me right back to
him and he goes like this and just left
and I was like that he made his bed bras
yes yes I'm not the maid it was
[ __ ] for me what the what was
him one more embarrassing things was
that very nobody knew me on this plane
and I said then I want to read this book
but I'm sitting next to this guy who is
not reading and I know he would love to
strike up a conversation because you got
nothing else to do right I got my book
right and I don't want to talk to
anybody cuz I want to read and sure
enough this guy sees me and he sit he's
got he's like two rows and he stops and
he goes oh [ __ ]
oh no and then
this guy and what I in the hangar I was
like this yeah this guy's like oh no no
no I got this actor oh I go sometimes
and he goes he goes you guys know this
is no yeah really no one knows where I
go nobody you're like what is it guys
come on man hangover yeah oh nothing
dude what are you doing what are you
[ __ ] doing here
so I got sorbetto barrel I know I don't
know kind of genetics I wasn't famous
enough for them to be bothered
everybody said like they're looking up
like one yeah so then and then he's
asking me questions ups but sure enough
guy next to me that was it
you're an actor yeah yeah yeah yeah now
I got to talk to him cuz i yeah but that
but it's actually rude people always
want to tell you when that happens like
oh I don't even know who you are what do
you you know they'll realize it's like
do you want era cereal did I know you
like don't take this thing go so in
committee [ __ ] should I know you oh my
god I am Ferris but I'm always like no I
guess not
I got I got I got there were people
taking pictures of me and then you know
when that happens people take pictures
with you and then other people are like
oh I should take a picture whatever yeah
I had that too and they don't know you
and they say can I get a picture with
you and I go like this I've done this
multiple times I say tell me who I am
there you go what if I been I don't know
is it you naked [ __ ] you're you know you
can be mean it's not me our kids not
malaria I mean I would like it not me I
cannot write in Raiders I mean maybe
somebody would think it's me but it's
[ __ ] that never happened to me it's
funny they know who I am
oh god Brian you did the funniest thing
one time in at the Comedy Store
my brother was there too and I remember
because of how hard he laughed and how
funny it was but we were with a bunch of
guys and girl I mean you know it was
just outside the patio and I don't even
know who they were but they're probably
like only kind of knew but you walked up
and I was like I look Brian here and you
grabbed you grab three of the girls and
guys around and you're just like posed
with them like it
like you like Digby you know like ready
to take the pic and they weren't asking
for a picture but you just did it and it
was so funny because like I named it I
just assumed yeah and they didn't know
what to do and it was so funny man
yeah I got er I was like sure sure yeah
yeah no fun but you just literally
grabbed them and took them in it was
really freeing Steen did that to me
backstage was backstage and I was
looking at him and he's timbers there's
my hero and I want to ask him for a
picture so badly but I didn't want to be
that guy and I was and he could see by
my body lines of standing there staring
at him like that and he goes come on ha
ha ha ha dad when when I was uh before I
was fighting I went to USC excellent
waiting this longest line to get
everyone's autograph and I only wanted
to get yeah we wanted right one guy's
autograph but you have to go through the
last one it seems like chocolate ice on
it and went Wanderley Silva Josh
Koscheck I really want his autograph
I just wanted [ __ ] wanderlei's and
the last guy Chuck Liddell's yeah so I
went in this line for two hours my sign
no see you doing that bro yeah so I was
super young and I would so I waiting
this line get to the front I get one
bleh spelled my name wrong so is it
Brandon I explained it to me like I just
move on I see cost Jake but it's awkward
I don't want an autograph just like it
ever is how you doing man no good he
signs my shirt ah really my shirt goes
how you doing brother I'm a lot damn it
and then I took like that and then just
go get my autograph never wear that
shirt again oh we just assumed was oh
yeah yeah yeah he's like good to see you
little bro of like mother thanks bro
have you been training it off whatever
II was in a suit that would be the best
if you're gonna suit with a tie and you
just [ __ ] I don't like I had like I'm
one was [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
Tapout Trinity held or did many oh my
god I always love it when people are
really excited to see you like I I find
it awesome woah it's so great oh I know
yeah it's awesome because it would this
podcasting [ __ ] could they listen to you
all the time yeah it is cool man maybe
should we go to current events
yeah I love coming here's coffee
anything you good I am gonna coffee you
want you on caffeine take a quick
general right will you take a break I
don't get it yeah we can take breaks
pick up and then what and then you come
back into current events
you'll some current events Jim I do so
up down the first one is this just
happened right now in Germany oh right
80,000 fans had to leave a music
festival because of a terrorist threat
that's the biggest pain yes I guess I
[ __ ] you guys hmm I don't know how that
how do they judge like what's worthy of
its it and we can just yeah the police
hit up the place and said you guys have
to leave there's a there's a real threat
must know legit yeah no no I understand
I just I mean obviously I know nothing
about it I just wonder what what
constitutes a legit threat they gets
threats or like efforts all the time
yeah all the time but there's ones that
are like super legit where they know
that action carried out they've been
doing it for so long they know you know
you know those be like yeah the
intelligence knows when something's like
a legit threat or someone just like
making kind of a hypothetical unit right
if they got 80,000 people to cancel this
concert that's super that difficut
80,000 people think about super super
legit Wow Jesus Christ not too bad no
nothing happened what just happened
right now though better to evacuate can
have somebody you know Arianny we just
went to Manchester to do another concert
yes I'm guessing this is gonna affect
that as well well no because the thing
about that is if her going back to
Manchester Security's can be so high to
super the terrorists aren't yet they're
like not we get that we're just going to
go over to Germany where's 80,000 people
they're not thinking about it but I'm
guessing she's gonna be freaking out
like if they just had a huge threat yeah
definitely man that's so well and then
I'd the tickets are high right yeah it
sold out like in six minutes
Wow enormous wrong well it's like we're
at Ariana Grande its Bieber its Katy
Perry Coldplay weather why they only
publicizing her because she's the one
who she's the one that was in the
terrorist attack right yeah [ __ ] man
that's crazy
huh baby he set it off after the show
actually no he set it off after she left
the stage right but everyone's still
there yes that's right yeah mmm okay
what else you're doing right this is
also battling but
yesterday Texas to Texas bounty hunters
found this guy who is only like in
trouble for drug charges but they found
him inside a Nissan dealership and they
were about to arrest him and I'll play
you the video it's pretty crazy
so someone inside the dealership
actually had a cell phone running at
this exact time these are the bounty
hunters right here because it dogged
about hillier it looks like him and
that's the
that's how hot they shoot that guys yeah
so the guy had a gun on him so when
they're taking him down he try to shoot
and they both shot at him all three of
them died it was like 20 shot oh my six
second gone all three of them got killed
all through no no one inside a
dealership but those guys the Bounty
Hunter is [ __ ] and the guy let me see
that again
that's the problem with people having
guns you don't know how yeah man how
everyone say everyone should have guns
really what's this I can your watch
what's this oh how many 20 shots yeah
okay watch seconds yeah it is hard to
watch hmm
damn damn I mean that that's that's got
to be how did everybody die but they're
all like a scene out of in glorious
battle all that Mexican stands yeah yeah
and probably because when the guy got
shot you don't die right away right away
depending a we go they might have shot
him in the shoulder his face down he
turns around
oh boo boo boo other planet in thank God
no one else it was hard yeah really that
goes to show you how quickly [ __ ] can
happen and when you're a cop and you're
you're under that tension yeah I just it
happened people realize how fast it
happened so so close ops how long did
that take how long 20 20 shots take
think about this for a second and cops
to know seconds well ops probably they
have a friend yo man you see Jay pull
that go over just a standard stop guy
turns around shoots him in the face so
cops hear all those horrible stories
yeah when they come up they're on the
edge it's because they've heard or and
they also know they can die even they're
shooting they can die right away I got
that back like that Viper bang and
they're dead - so you're high along here
in LA there's a space like a bounty on
police officers now all the like the big
game to have bounties on the LA Times
now yeah because all the black violence
and black on black crime that's the
thing as I said for a cop unless you've
been there and you understand that kind
of thing do you see how quickly it is
how how you pay a price with your life
and you're dealing with a guy who might
be a criminal or he has a gun on them
you see something flash and you're you
know whatever bat you shoot because
you're you're afraid
it really doesn't know these guys
yeah hops I don't know what the
background is but no for drug charges
it's kind of like let's Intel that guy
that guy was clearly ready to shoot and
kill it sorry tried to grab he wasn't
going to jail so that's a dangerous
[ __ ] right so I don't know I
mean Jesus dangerous work dangerous what
else she does heart this is a little
lighter
can you read their award most like you
to blend in with white people sending
Caesar
so her teacher a joke right I mean yeah
that's the thing so her teacher gave
these two words one was that one and
another one's one most likely to become
a terrorist rich and so she got
suspended
hey didn't uh fire fire yet they could
do an investigation but no one knows why
she did this she gave actual awards and
she wrote it down like a like she
premeditated this she was black as well
I don't even know that either probably
it's most likely to fit in with white
peope my name of the white people most
like to be a terrorist what is wrong
there might be like some like stuff that
they've been talking about in class and
you know yeah most of it look could you
saw my dad um inside Joker's yeah I got
her daughter like so upset she skipped
class Anika day it sounds I got like an
inside joke gone bad yeah I mean had to
have been oh just being an idiot maybe a
[ __ ] dude I was watching this mini
doctor actually was a mini Doc's on
20/20 for God's sakes 10 o'clock at
night there's this teacher who you know
super religious dude family two kids and
this girl came she had no friends he
like took under wing butter to church
and then ah see you know start writing
songs for like these love songs ends up
talking into dipping out with him he
just leaves his family everything they
go on to the base beyond [ __ ] eluding
the police now how old is he I'm sorry
she's 15 and you laugh he's 48 no no no
he's 48 they say I told you hey you lad
he left maybe you think that's what you
think this is funny banana being the
show spotty are you nothing but don't
wait now but so he they say he screwed
he's in prison they're saying for life
for in
oh I know they're saying they you know
he's basically use mind control over to
get her day and which came back and it's
one of the ways they comedies picked up
a prescription of cialis they had been
in love like I not love but he'd been
they've been kind of quote-unquote
already had having a relationship they
brought up some of these taxes like he
goes get rid of forty eight he goes when
you bent over and picked up that
backpack that and oh wow fifteen years
old into dundun in but is not making
excuses I was planning it fake drama
stir to that I make an experience
complete excuses but a little dated oh
no but they were have you know to me
yeah you're making excuses for that yeah
[ __ ] crazy in some countries today
that would not be considered out of the
ordinary no I don't mean marry her off
of course the rich forty a very common
hop will you throughout hating you like
it even hate your condo and his Google
search was what countries is it alright
to marry a fifteen-year-old like all
this stuff yep yes what his plan was
and then we all laughed about it me and
the people on TVs investigators is he
was going to leave from there in
Oklahoma some [ __ ] they didn't leave
from Oklahoma sneaked all the way to
California and he had a canoe there to
paddle to Mexico the faith he was
thinking you're thinking what they're
like well everyone's like he's a very
smart man like that's why they couldn't
catch him like until the one kind of
bump in the road he didn't have a
motorized boat he had a canoe for this
fifteen year old and his forty
eight-year-old ass was going to canoe
you know far that is I've come to San
Diego all the way to Mexico I would take
you till the millennia that you know
you're not going to make even and he
goes even professional like guys who
rolled out and couldn't make this
journey a job you'd be a mom gonna canoe
a stroke eight foot swells can do as to
our paradise honey hey drive try get a
speedboat just
summary intron draw summary oh you know
what don't do any of it
yeah well don't know you know I don't
kidnap a fifteen-year-old wait till
she's 18 king also look like I do a lot
I can do wait till you're can you wait
three years right I'll tell you what the
red flag was she recorded a song that he
performed for and like put it on
Instagram and
like finally we're alone I feel like I'm
falling in love you're the one for me
and it shows all the subtitles Stan I'm
like how do you not how to so as a alert
PD I really catchy gems nice real catchy
when you have a daughter as I do the one
thing that the women in your family will
tell you is no male babysitter's no
teenage boys no Evan and you just never
trust any man to be alone in a house
with your daughter
yeah I don't give a [ __ ] room who would
know no one but he has no arms and legs
alright even then you know I even and
stay why well here's the deal I wouldn't
even want to be alone with that's right
then you use that's right Evan you know
that when I taught I was out all night
never know what people were going to
think not I mean I love you tweet out oh
my god this guy made a pass at me if I
was in a room with him [ __ ] in the 13
year old I would be leaving that room
immediately anybody who doesn't is weird
well I'll call my Eddie get in here get
in so come in hello when I was 18 19 19
19 20 I was a counselor at this thing I
was teaching kids Taekwondo as a summer
camp the kids were eight nine and 10 or
whatever and when I was in the classroom
alone summer time
yep even I was it was think I was in
this class alone and there was you there
was usually a girl with me and she went
to do something and I remember the older
woman came in and said look I mean you
don't I didn't even think about shoes
you can't be in this room alone and let
me tell you why if a kid says one thing
whatever it is your life is ruined I
never forgot it I was like huh yeah but
I'm not what are you talking about it
was the last thing on my mind well you
know that's the reality of it don't be
in the room so they never let you be in
the room alone even back then I had to
have that that girl was there she was
also a life police so and I hooked up
with that girl anyway so that it makes
you look at the dirt dirty boy and I was
with the the the other counselor that I
was with because she was ever been 19 so
we fought gay guy did you down well Fox
over to borrow some are you doing again
tear us [ __ ] I'm not a put you wouldn't
you would have been scared what do you
mean back off
what a food alright the next one Wonder
Woman is banned in uh that's my girl
movie patty Jenkins you bastards how
dare they do you know why why so Lebanon
or oh wait a minute yeah so it's been
eleven on but then Israel and Lebanon
had like oh that's really really that's
right she's not just Israeli she was
part of their Israeli Defense Forces
dying two years all women are all in
Israel it's mandatory
yeah forget it in Israel it's mandatory
she's like women and men she's
hopelessly hey for you now you know what
now what are you saying I'm gonna handle
it she was wrong you're uh you're a
grisly anymore what are you sued be
[ __ ] you what bro not for you hey
stand down boy oh boy
Stanley bro hey the water seed with
Taschen mass you know what bro how about
this man I don't even [ __ ] bro I [ __ ]
make sweet love I swear to god man not
don't you think you're [ __ ] [ __ ]
mail stuff I push slow I'm nice about it
man hell I don't
power I push that how is she looking for
yeah she is right you know I'll tell you
that my wonder woman I don't want to
give girls what they look for
I want to give girls what they need hey
alright and dude mono guy oh I'll do it
oh yeah well I'm gonna do it better
coming full circle that's my girl patty
Jenkins movie go see Wonder Woman it it
premieres this weekend yeah but hey this
podcast gets here next week so
definitely send all right we'll keep
seeing it you [ __ ] dogged oh uh well hi
piece of all dime pieces she's the best
yet hey guys I'm she's the bad I'm
snapchatting this aqua boring boring hey
Chris you're well have a very good voice
too thank you singer can you sing it
also or II remember when we tried to
sing for real home and I start Latino
high all night yep it was so hard so
hard it's all darlin you're [ __ ]
though right dead serious told me and
Rogin if you go back 20 years he would
go beyond it gone to be a singer
yeah hey that's why are you hard fellow
that's what I want to do I never
understood I never understood the allure
of being a rock star I know everybody
secretly wants to be a rock star I would
never want to do that they say every
comedian deep down wants to be a rock
star I don't know that that no they say
every athlete wants to be a rush sir
right and then every rock star wonder
you see no tariffs no no the same song
over and over
i watch Slean Dion and seeing that
Titanic song my heart will go on
you don't wait time just to see you know
our duck song is yeah yeah big song yeah
I know I can say it you can't I got
every notice the same with you oh well
other yet Wonder Woman I've no desire to
see it I hope it does what I would see
I've known as I see it was great I saw I
went to be a premier was awesome i'ma
wait for it to go on demands to sell you
do it was great I've no desire to see it
I don't like acting losing jealous just
wimp what else yes good hey man she
can't that's our girls movie well not
this only this one he actually got away
with wearing that on his head for his
Arizona driver's license like spaghetti
it's kind of fun graduating I like that
for you they were not letting my podcast
congratulations guys looking good man
did you you everyone should download
they they wouldn't let me smile my new
passport photo guy goes could smiling
tonight really she goes I guess that's
funny Wow okay so check this got
somebody that Brian would [ __ ] every
day like he wants to come to your show
set him up with tickets Thunderbird said
you'd have to talk to for 35 minutes he
was sick we TC is for guys you say oh
that's a big strong dude yeah but all
matter or doesn't you not want to 2007
want any part of that [ __ ] would he go
my guys got baby I find fit oh you can't
do that well you definitely can't do it
visit ease in jail no well of course it
feels like a smart male with a tattoo on
his neck
says what am i weird you can't do that
I'm sure he loves his baby but you can't
do that a [ __ ] [ __ ] he's a macho guy
thinks he's in totally frustrating
[ __ ] I just made it I know much of guys
are that's stupid that's that how do I
already talked to that crazy god what
the [ __ ] you know but they're not good
little sketch also that bed Oh God
how about this yeah I saw that you know
people are doing that nowadays they do
like they'll make themselves a girl make
yourself right on right now oh they go
Johnny Depp don't leave it on cliff face
that's what it's called chocolate face
yeah you did back to the day like actors
do it yeah yeah back when before black
oh yeah chocolate so yeah did she get in
trouble for this or summer I believe
this is here see but they definitely got
in trouble they got a bunch of backlash
she what I mean that's a woman right
before the makeup artist is the one why
would they get in trouble for that she
feels great laughs Tom looks great she
looks great in both rooms yeah to me
Shirley black on the right I was like
she got a tan on the oh really looks
like a white girl some DSL exactly why
would you be in trouble lately with
blockers just changing your look Oh
glamour that I saw this when it was post
I don't know why was on my explore page
or something like that whatever because
yeah but I mean I don't have to it's not
about raising is about war more I Drive
who gives a [ __ ] so she wanted to get
creative with her makeup and go racist
you refine that raises our semanas only
I asked her that no is it racist at all
what happened if I paint in my face
black it's never impossible to have a
problem solve IT bro yeah I know
I [ __ ] hate him it's the truth I
really do it's like [ __ ] off oh well
this year I have a piece of candy am i
all right [ __ ] phone how about this
Jim Carrey defended a Kathy Griffin so
did Jamie Foxx and their whole point was
like you know she's a comedian that's
your job to push the boundaries you know
find the line and no one knows what the
line is so you have to keep trying
what happened to Jim Carrey that's a
great beard so well beer is a new show
on Showtime yeah but no he's not in it
already
yeah he's the producer yeah no yeah no
but yeah he rejected produce you know I
know that yeah okay
but I thought we were coming on the
beard and that's why you said well he's
got a new show he's got to have the
beard
not saying that I do public spotlight
again goddamn man watch your mouth about
Jim Carrey Jim kick I'm not I love Jim
Carrey I'm not talking [ __ ] about him
yeah
yes actually he's my favorite no he's
not
yes he is my favorite [ __ ] one of my
favorite comedian not in nua he's not
doing as much acting anymore he's and
just self-help talking yeah it's really
interesting he says so much money but
you lot [ __ ] everything I'm happy with
all of its now he's trying to do it yeah
maybe oh yeah you know you know him
really well yes
[ __ ] dumb [ __ ] just saying [ __ ]
people yes I do know him thank you nod
he's a friend that's what you said so
what did Jamie Foxx say same thing like
a comedian it's their job to you know
cross the line to figure out where the
line is because it doesn't exist
mm-hmm and that's how you find out if
it's funny or not but I mean everyone
pretty much agrees that it's not funny
yeah what was I stopped thinking about
it will be like a long time ago yeah I
was just like god that's not funny movie
yeah yeah yeah who cares her yeah I
don't I don't hate her I don't know yeah
I don't have any issue I was like a
something she wants [ __ ] for that anyway
you know how to moved on with my day
it's making her more famous and you're
absolutely great murderer ticket prices
will double yeah no we don't know this
you know what you don't even know okay
you don't know and you say it like it's
on a document and that's where I get all
[ __ ] pissed off
it's nobody writers are going to double
name is they might you know what dude
they might no no no no no I don't know
yeah whoo
nah I've been around bro I know this
should work what else you got Hey can I
leave all about we're almost done with
this bro [ __ ] I'm hungry and you have
a spread no right if I can't win show
you got a spread yeah [ __ ] yeah dude
we're gonna say if you do that your
house then a little budget [ __ ] it it's
just me [ __ ] at your house
I got a tech ed hey you know burger
burgers you do you have a steerable
prize ah hahaha you later when comes out
it wasn't too late yeah you're talking
to a mic you low-rent [ __ ] one
of them
so listen here live from Christmas house
you [ __ ] idiot isn't sent your
podcast is if you guys listening this
boycott it alright alright this is a bad
one but it's pretty fascinating sixteen
year old girl she went to a Walmart
stole a knife and a machete ordered Oh
Boober and then she hacked him to death
what what this is all I was not handed
up for five weeks and this is the [ __ ]
that Canadian see and they're like dude
it's crazy in America and they're right
so she's a complete sociopath she just
wanted to kill somebody in years old she
bought the knife at Walmart stole what I
want a psycho
a machete an ax and a knife and she
started stabbing the guy called maneuver
he came to pick her up and then as soon
as she got in she just started hacking
on him and then he was able to escape
and then run into or run to of in front
of a building and buzz the buttons but
he's like I'm gonna die when I die cuz
he's bleeding out so he eventually died
dude that's so insane it was completely
unprovoked - so she just wanted to tell
somebody that's a lasting thing of 16
year-olds gonna kill me that's her what
you know looks like a brother Stephen do
and mentally out of her mind so he's
probably like how's your night in the
knife [ __ ] out of her [ __ ] stone look
at her
yeah like I just don't have your midriff
out though huh we're saying okay God
Hales is don't lie down no I don't like
that bro get up hey real quick Chris are
those jeans or sweats these are [ __ ]
both bro I do hybrid tango pic get on it
ginger sweats
you know it's [ __ ] up I had a great
dropping knowledge but it's on my phone
my phone just died I'm so disrespectful
all right let's wrap the head back on
black guys yeah there's no great
dropping knowledge said [ __ ] up hey I'm
smarter [ __ ] dropping knowledge ladies
and gentlemen thank you so much for
Chris well thanks for come on what you
guys doing listen to what's he closed
congratulations
iTunes everywhere he is out of his
garage with his my dog with his [ __ ]
hey can't be a guest I'm congratulations
I'll have to check on what I decided
hi did you want to know the answers yeah
and a complete waste of time
hey can't do it
book your off but with Hill you me I got
me on it forever
you don't need torn there's you just
give up on coming to strictly I got all
[ __ ] shows all over the place man I'm
gonna go to Montreal i'ma go to
Baltimore I'm gonna go West Palm Beach
I'm gonna go to [ __ ] Atlantic City I
don't feel I look everybody I'm going to
be at the Irvine improv Matt Chris is
opening for me no I'm not
June 8 not even had a Chris I said it's
gonna open up do 90 minutes I had luck
following that uh [ __ ] good [ __ ] you
be you everyone given the dates again
turn 8th 9th and 10th on man and as you
guys listen uh Simon Oscars there's only
tickets left in the early sean sub in
Sydney and in Auckland New Zealand hey
don't be a theater has been coming for
three minutes now uh but there's your
pani asked show dude nailed you are I'm
in New York Gotham comedy club June 22nd
TPAC ad I'm producing his podcast is
ngratulations that my special man on
fire comes out soon on Netflix okay a
date though if they soon they're not on
fire Jude June 27 net rats while you're
waiting Evans yep his new special each
man on fire oh there's no Washington
explosion even though you'll yeah then
done little did it then wow you and
Denzel now that's awesome this is a
finally kid would crystally up we're out
I talk about it